Un pour tous, tous pour un.
Cette devise vous dit sûrement
quelque chose ?
C'est celle des Trois Mousquetaires
d'Alexandre Dumas.
Mais ces personnages ont
ils vraiment existé ?
Et d'Artagnan, d'où sort il ?
Thibaut de la chaîne Histoire Appliquée a
enfilé sa cape et son chapeau,
et vous allez le voir, ça ne manque pas de panache.
Bonjour Jamy et bonjour à tous.
Quand on pense aux trois mousquetaires,
on imagine
généralement de grands gaillards,
barbe et moustache bien taillés,
maniant l'épée avec brio
dans des duels insensés
au service du roi de France.
Deux gars
qui me ressemblent un peu finalement.
Un peu.
Bref, les vrais mousquetaires du roi
correspondent
ils à cette image véhiculée
par la littérature et le cinéma ?
Pour y répondre, effectuons
un petit voyage dans le passé.
Direction le XIXᵉ siècle,
plus précisément le mois de mars 1844.
Il y a tout pile 179 ans.
Cette année là, Alexandre Dumas,
qui est déjà un auteur de théâtre
bien connu, publie son nouveau roman,
Les Trois Mousquetaires.
L'histoire est simple,
mais diablement efficace.
Un jeune Gascon désargenté de 18 ans
nommé d'Artagnan
débarque dans le Paris du XVIIᵉ siècle
sous le règne de Louis XII.
Il va intégrer le corps des Mousquetaires,
un poste ô combien prestigieux.
Impétueux et doté d'un cœur gros comme ça,
il se lie d'amitié avec trois d'entre eux
Athos, Porthos et Aramis.
Ensemble, les quatre compères
vont voler d'aventures en aventures
pour sauver Louis XII,
la reine et le royaume de France.
À de multiples reprises,
les aventures des Trois Mousquetaires
deviennent en quelques mois
un véritable phénomène de société.
Des histoires
d'amour compliquées, du mystère,
un contexte historique séduisant,
du panache et de l'élégance.
La recette est imparable.
Dumas pique les lecteurs au cœur.
Chaque semaine, les lecteurs du journal
Le Siècle attendent
la suite de leurs aventures.
Un peu comme on attend le messie.
En fait, les Français découvrent
les trois mousquetaires
dans la presse sous la forme d'un roman
feuilleton au XIXᵉ siècle.
Il est en effet très fréquent
de publier les romans d'aventures
dans les journaux en plusieurs épisodes.
Le Comte de Monte-Cristo ou Arsène
Lupin plus tard
seront également publiés dans la presse
en plusieurs épisodes,
avant d'être disponibles en librairie.
Le roman feuilleton, c'est
un peu l'ancêtre de nos séries télé.
Alors à l'époque,
les Mousquetaires d'Alexandre
Dumas sont si populaires
que de nombreux lecteurs sont persuadés
qu'ils ont vraiment existé.
Alors, à votre avis, est ce vrai ou faux ?
Je vous donne la réponse un peu plus tard.
Intéressons nous d'abord aux
vrais mousquetaires, pas ceux du roman.
Ils appartiennent à une unité d'élite
créée par Louis XII en 1622.
Celui ci décide de détacher de la Garde
royale 50 cavaliers
triés sur le volet
pour former une unité indépendante.
On les appelle les mousquetaires du roi
et ce sont avant tout
des militaires formés pour le combat.
Mais ils constituent aussi
la garde rapprochée du monarque.
Ils les escortent,
Louis XII, dans tous ses déplacements
et assurent sa sécurité 20 4 h sur 24.
C'est un peu l'équivalent de notre GSPR,
le groupe de sécurité
de la présidence de la République.
Et bien évidemment, ils sont armés.
La particularité de ce corps,
c'est que ses membres sont équipés
d'une arme révolutionnaire le mousquet.
Un ancêtre du fusil d'où le nom
de ceux qui en sont équipés,
les mousquetaires.
Le canon est très long
et l'arme très lourde entre trois
et cinq kilogrammes
avec une cadence de tir assez faible
parce qu'il
faut recharger après chaque tir.
Insérer la poudre, la balle,
désamorcer le mousquet
si encombrante
qu'il est impossible de tirer à cheval,
les soldats doivent mettre pied à terre,
puis épauler,
comme on le fait avec un fusil classique.
C'est tellement peu pratique
que sur le champ de bataille,
les mousquetaires utilisent une fourche
qui est une sorte de piquet
en forme de fourche
qui sert de support au canon.
Malgré toutes ces contraintes,
Les Mousquetaires
excelle dans son maniement.
Il faut dire que les armes, c'est
un peu leur dada.
Aux mousquetaires du roi,
ils sont beaucoup plus hargneux
et bagarreurs que les personnages du roman
parce qu'ils ne sont pas à la guerre.
Il passe l'essentiel
de leur temps à se battre en duel.
Mais pour ça, évidemment,
ils n'utilisent pas leur mousquet,
mais une épée qu'on appelle la rapière.
Au XVIIᵉ siècle, ce sont les pérennes,
celle que tout le monde utilise en Europe.
Elle est légère, efficace et mortelle.
En France,
la rapière connaît un grand succès,
mais un succès à double tranchant.
Les duels entraînent de lourdes pertes
chez les jeunes nobles,
et les mousquetaires n'échappent
bien entendu pas à la règle.
Ce qui ne tombe pas
au combat périsse en duel
et on dit d'ailleurs qu'un mousquetaire
qui atteint les 30 ans,
c'est un mousquetaire chanceux
ou bien qui manque de courage.
Mais peu importe aux yeux du peuple,
il incarne l'image d'hommes audacieux,
généreux
et indestructibles,
qui n'ont peur de rien ni personne.
Les Mousquetaires est à mi chemin
entre la canaille magnifique
et le noble guerrier.
Ah oui, j'avais oublié de vous
le préciser,
les mousquetaires sont des nobles.
C'est
un critère de sélection incontournable.
Je vous confirme, j'aime.
Pour en être, il faut être bien né.
Les candidats issus
des grandes familles aristocratiques
ont plus de chances d'être engagés
que les membres de la petite noblesse.
Plus surprenant,
il est préférable d'être originaire
du Béarn ou de Gascogne,
ce qui est le cas de notre fameux
d'Artagnan.
Du coup, ce personnage est
il vraiment sorti de l'imagination
d'Alexandre Dumas ?
Eh bien non, il a vraiment existé.
L'écrivain l'a trouvé dans une biographie
écrite par un certain Gatien de Courtise
de Sandra.
Elle relate la vie de Charles,
base de Castelnau,
un mousquetaire mort au combat en 1673.
L'auteur rapporte qu'il est né à Lupiac,
dans le Gers, autour de 1611,
dans une famille noble.
Très tôt, ce Bax de Castel,
maure nourrit une grande ambition
Il veut devenir mousquetaire du roi.
Mais on l'a dit, pour avoir une chance
d'être recruté, il faut être issu
de la grande noblesse,
ce qui n'est absolument pas son cas.
Les bases de Castelmaurou
n'ont été que récemment anoblis.
Quand il a l'âge de s'engager,
il décide de se présenter
sous un autre nom, d'Artagnan.
Ce n'est pas vraiment un mensonge
car il est apparenté
à cette grande famille par sa mère
et c'est bien joué.
Cette usurpation d'identité
lui ouvre toutes les portes.
En 1633, son rêve devient réalité
il est promu mousquetaire.
Ça me va bien.
Donnez moi votre avis en commentaire.
d'Artagnan va servir Louis XII
jusqu'à la mort du roi en 1643.
Les mousquetaires sont dissous en 1646.
d'Artagnan entre un peu
après au service de la régente
Anne d'Autriche.
Elle dirige le royaume
d'une main de maître
et du redoutable cardinal Mazarin.
À leurs côtés, ils traversent
une période trouble la Fronde.
Des affrontements
éclatent un peu partout dans Paris.
Parmi les conjurés, il y a des gens
du peuple, de la bourgeoisie,
mais aussi une partie de la noblesse
qui rêvent de renverser la couronne.
d'Artagnan ne bronche pas.
Il reste fidèle à Anne d'Autriche.
Ce dévouement lui vaut
la confiance du jeune Louis XIV
et lui permet de relancer
sa carrière militaire.
Du coup,
lorsque la Compagnie des Mousquetaires
est reconstituée en 1657,
il en prend tout naturellement la tête.
À ce titre,
d'Artagnan est même chargé d'escorter
le souverain à Saint-Jean-de-Luz
en 1660 pour son mariage
avec l'infante d'Espagne.
En 1661.
C'est aussi à lui que l'on confie
l'arrestation de Nicolas Fouquet,
le puissant ministre
des Finances de Louis XIV,
qui est accusé
d'avoir détourné l'argent du royaume.
Il assure sa surveillance en prison
pendant trois ans.
Enfin, honneur suprême,
il est nommé gouverneur de Lille
en décembre 1672.
Cette grande cité
tient un rôle stratégique
majeur pour la France,
mais c'est en militaires
que notre mousquetaire
finit sa vie en 1673.
Coup du destin,
il est tué sur le champ de bataille,
abattu par une balle de mousquet.
Voilà pour le personnage historique
et ce qu'on en fait.
Cette biographie
est probablement un peu romancée,
mais elle regorge d'anecdotes
et de personnages
qu'Alexandre Dumas utilise pour parfaire
ses histoires.
C'est d'ailleurs dans ce livre
qu'on y trouve aussi
le nom de deux de ces mousquetaires,
Henri David,
qu'il transforme en Aramis
et Isaac de Porto, qui devient Porthos.
En revanche, Thibaut,
la fameuse devise des Mousquetaires
Un pour tous, tous pour un,
Eh bien, c'est totalement faux.
Elle n'a jamais servi de devise
au mousquetaire du roi.
C'est en réalité la traduction en français
d'une vieille locution latine
qui sert aujourd'hui
de devise non officielle de la Suisse.
Et on s'en fiche que ce soit faux
puisque c'est
un roman et que dans un roman,
on a le droit de tout inventer.
Plus incroyable encore, un pour tous,
tous pour un est en réalité
une citation erronée.
Elle n'apparaît jamais sous cette forme
dans le roman,
mais sous la forme inversée.
Tous pour un, un pour tous.
Mais au fait, les vrais mousquetaires,
que sont ils devenus
après la mort de Louis XIV ?
Ils ont traversé son règne sans encombre
Mais les deux compagnies de mousquetaires,
parce qu’il y en avait deux,
ça coute très cher à entretenir.
et à partir du XVIIIᵉ siècle,
on fait de moins en moins appel à elle.
Si bien qu'en 1775,
les mousquetaires sont purement
et simplement supprimés
pour faire des économies.
Des années plus tard, en 1814,
Louis X huit
tente de rétablir les mousquetaires.
Histoire de restaurer le faste d'antan.
Après la période napoléonienne.
Mais ça ne va pas durer longtemps.
Au bout d'un an, à peine un an,
ils sont de nouveau priés
de rentrer chez eux,
toujours par mesure d'économie.
En tout cas,
les mousquetaires du roi doivent
une fière chandelle à Alexandre Dumas.
C'est grâce à lui
que ces valeureux militaires
n'ont pas sombré
dans les oubliettes de l'Histoire.
Aujourd'hui,
les mousquetaires sont partout
au cinéma bien sûr, au théâtre,
à l'opéra, dans les bandes dessinées.
Savez vous qu'il existe aussi
une série de marionnettes
japonaises, Les Trois Mousquetaires,
une série coréenne,
un film égyptien, un autre Mexicain,
un Russe, des parodies,
un ballet australien.
La liste est longue.
Plus proche de nous,
la France a décidé de se doter
d'une équipe nationale de football
américain pour la Ligue européenne.
Mais connais tu son nom ?
Les Mousquetaires de Paris, bien entendu.
Merci Thibaut.
Je suis sûr que dans une autre vie,
tu as été un grand mousquetaire
comme d'Artagnan.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez
pas à mettre un pouce bleu
et à vous abonner.
Et surtout, indiquez nous en commentaire
les sujets d'histoire que vous aimez.
On regardera ça très près avec Thibault.
À très bientôt,
chers Épicurieux et Épicurieuses.